اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير وحيكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
اعلان الاداره الامريكيه اعاده تقييم
العلاقات مع السعوديه كانت خطوه حقيقيه ام
مجرد تصريحات اعلاميه لرفع الحرج عن اداره
بايدن بعد قرارات بخفض الانتاج
تسريبات الوثائق السريه الامريكيه تضليل
من واشنطن للجيش الروسي ام حيله من موسكو
والهجوم بمسيره على مدار السليمانيه هل
كان هدفه اغتيال اكبر مسؤول عسكري كردي ام
هو خلط للاوراق لاهداف انتخابيه تركيه كما
يقول قائد قاسات
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اجبرت بعيدا على اعاده التفكير في نهجه
الفاتر تجاه الرياض في ظل الزراعي واشنطن
للحد من اسعار النفط المرتفعه ولكن يبدو
ان الرياض ليست على استعداد لمسايره توجه
لواشن الجديد وفق الصحيفه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في شؤون السياسيه
الامريكيه ومن لندن الدكتور مصطفى
البزركان الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي
والطاقه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا مع الدكتور عقيل دكتور عقيل كما
تعلم حضرتك السنه الماضيه اواخر السنه
الماضيه كانت هناك تصريحات لبايدن تحدث
فيها بشكل صريحا انه ينوي اعاده تقييم
العلاقات مع السعوديه هذه تصريحات
استذكرتها الصحيفه الامريكيه بوليتيكو على
اثر تصريحات لمسؤولين امريكيين تحدثت
اليهم وقالوا لها بانه لم تكن هناك في
الواقع اعاده تقييم وانما مداولاته غير
رسميه حتى وبالتالي سؤال المطروح ان لم
تكن هناك
نيه جديه من اداره بايدن لاعاده تقييم هذه
العلاقات ما الداعي للتصريحات
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه تحيه لكي الكريم
يعني انا بتصور تصريحات في حينها كانت
مفاجاه ومبالغه بها في العاده العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه تحصل فيها خلافات
واحيانا خلافات جديه لكن يجري التعاطي
معها بهدوء هذه المره كان اعلالا مفاجئا
وبتصوري في جزء منه كان انعكاسا لتصريحات
الشد
مفاجاه الشد تحديا من الكونجرس فيها قدر
من رساله سياسيه للسعوديه انك تحتاجون ان
تعملوا معنا من اجل الحفاظ على تحالفنا
لكن في جوهرها انا اعتقد هو كانت اندفاع
مبالغ بها من الاداره الامريكيه في لحظتها
يعني عندما ظهر ان هناك ما يبدو استقلالا
سعوديا او خليجيا عن القرار الامريكي او
الرغبات الامريكيه بخصوص انتاج النفط ثم
تدريجيا اعتقد تراجعت الاشياء
متانه العلاقه الاقتصاديه بين الطرفين
ظهرت السعوديه يعني عقد الصفقه مع بوينج
37 مليار دولار تصنيع بحدود 121 طائره هذه
لوحدها تشغل 140 الف امريكي
على امتداد 44 ولايه في الولايات المتحده
يعني هناك اشياء تتعلق بالاقتصاد باحساس
امريكا انه علاقتها الرصينه اقتصاديا مع
السعوديه ليست في تراجع وانها لا صحيح
سنعود الى هذا الجانب الاقتصادي ولكنك
دكتور عقيل تقرا بان هذه التصريحات كانت
تصريحات غير محسوبه دكتور مصطفى هل تتفق
مع ضيفي على انه كان هناك اندفاع كانت
هناك تصريحات غير محسوبه من الرئيس
الامريكي ام بالعكس هذه التصريحات هي
لخدمه بروباجندا اعلاميه كان هو يقف
ورائها اتحدث عن رئيس الامريكي
قد يصح هذا ولكن لابد انه نعلم انه كافه
التصريحات هي لديها اتجاهها اتجاه خارجي
بمعنى
للراي العام العالمي واتجاه داخلي بمعنى
الراي العام الداخلي الامريكي
وحزب الجمهوري ولذلك شهدنا هذا هذا
التصريح هذا لم ياتي عفويا يعني كان هو
عمليه ان صح التعبير تنفيس
لهناك بعض الاتجاهات داخل الكونجرس بهذا
الاتجاه باتجاه التصعيد مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكن ظهرت خلال الاشهر
الماضيه انه هناك ما تحققه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لم تتمكن الولايات
المتحده من تحقيقه ولذلك الاشهر الماضيه
شهدت سياسه موزونه واستراتيجيه سعوديه
واضحه تجاه ملفات كثيره يعني عمليه
التقارب
والعلاق اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
العلاقات
العميقه مع العراق هناك ايضا لا ننسى
العلاقات الدوليه مع الصين مع
روسيا هذه جميعها تجعل ان هناك قلق في
الاداره الامريكيه هذه نقطه النقطه
الثانيه لابد من تاكيد انه اداره بايدن
تعاني من تخبط تخبط سياسي وحتى تخبط فيه
في مجال الطاقه ولذلك شهدنا هذا الاخذ هو
العطاء هناك نقطه لابد من ذكرها لابد
للاداره الامريكيه انه تعيد النظر في
علاقتها مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ايجابيا وليس سلبيا وبالتالي التوصل الى
قواسم مشتركه خاصه حينما نعلم انه
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
هي العلاقات من كل دول المنطقه تعود الى
عام 1933 صحيح هو ايضا وقتها كان يتحدث عن
اعاده تقييم سلبيه كما فهمنا من تصريحاته
خاصه وانه اشار الى عواقب محتمله ولكنك
تقرا بان هناك تخبط في هذه التصريحات
وانقل هذه النقطه لك دكتور عقيل هذا
التخبط في الواقع ضيفي يقول دكتور مصطفى
يقول بان اداره بايدن تشكو من تخبط في
ادارتها لسياساتها الخارجيه البعض يقول
بانه على امتداد الحكومات السابقه من براك
اوباما وصولا الى بايدن باستثناء فترات في
حكم ترامب كان هناك تخبط شديد وتذكر معي
الخطوط الحمراء مثلا التي تحدث عنها
اوباما فيما يخص شان السوري لن ندخل في
تفاصيل شان السوري ولكن بشكل عام هل هناك
ازمه تشكو منها الادارات الامريكيه
المتعاقبه طيله السنوات الفائته
يعني انا لن اقول ان لديها ازمه بخصوص
اداره علاقاتها الخارجيه او ان هناك تخبطا
واسعا لا هناك اخطاء او نعتقد التصريح
الذي قاله بايدن في حينه كان اندفاع بدت
اندفاعها عاطفيه يعني انت كنت تزور هذا
البلد قبل شهرين يعني زياره عاليه المستوى
عليها تسليط كثير من الاضواء ثم
فجاه يعني تاتي بهذا التصريح الغاضب
الاشياء لم تنته اسمح لي فقط دكتور عقيل
كيف ان ينزلق في هكذا انتفاع عاطفي كما
اسميت خاصه وان له تاريخ سياسي هو كان
نائب لبراك اوباما وهو رئيس دوله عظمى
دوله كبيره ولا تاريخ سياسي منذ شبابه
يعني مش مش منذ سنوات
ايضا له تاريخ في انه يعني يسمح الاشياء
ان تخرج من قبل ان يفكر بها بشكل عام يعني
وهذه واحده من الاشياء التي يمسكها علي
عليه الخصم لكن انا لا اعتقد انه فقط كانت
اندفاع نعتقد هو شخصيا شعر بجرح في
الكرامه انه
اعتقد انه توصل الى اتفاق بخصوص النفط ثم
فيما بعد دول اوبك يعني بزعامه السعوديه
قررت ان تذهب مع مصالحها الاقتصاديه
المشروعه
اعتقد هذا جانب منه جانب اخر ضغط من من
الكونجرس والجانب الاخر هو شخصيته يعني
هذه لحظات معقده لكن الواضح انه لم يجري
العمل يعني معظمنا وانا منهم كنت اترقب ما
الذي يعني ما وعد به الرئيس ما الذي
سيعنيه بالضبط مراجعه العلاقه لكن مع
متابعه الموضوع لم يصدر اي تصريح حتى
عندما تتحدث مع مصادر داخليه يحاول ان
يتهربوا من الموضوع يعني يبدو انه كان
هناك احساس انه هذه لحظه اندفاع لحظه
مبالغه فضلا عن ان الوقائع التي حدثت
بعدها لم تبرر استمرار هذا النوع من الغضب
يعني تعاطل السعوديه مع الولايات المتحده
في اطار اقتصاديه في اطر اخرى
المساعده السعوديه لاوكرانيا انخفاض سعر
النفط انخفاض سعر الغاز يعني لم يكن ممكنا
او معقولا تحميل كل شيء على كتف السعوديه
اسعار النفط حتى العراق حليف الولايات
المتحده هو الان يخفض يدعو الى تخفيض
الانتاج من اجل مطهر عالمي لذلك ولكن
دكتور مصطفى ان اتفقنا كلنا على ان الحرج
او الاحراج من وضع واشنطن امام امر واقع
اتخذته بقياده الرياض بخفض انتاج النفط هو
الذي دفع بايدن بهكذا تصريحات لماذا احرج
الى هذا او الى هذه الدرجه ما الذي يمكن
ان يمثله هذا الجانب الاقتصادي في قرارات
بايدن في محاولته للدفع بالاقتصاد
الامريكي كذلك فيما يخص هذه النقطه
كان هناك وعود قبل فوزه في الانتخابات
ولكن هناك نقطه اساسيه وهي انه اعود واكرر
حتى في مجال الطاقه وفي مجال البيئه هناك
تخبط لاداره بايدن لماذا لانه هو في في
تصريحاته في بدايه
رئاسته قالب الحرف الواحد انه لا بد من
الانتهاء من الاعتماد على النفط والغاز
والتوجه الى الطاقه المتجدده عاد قبل يعني
مع حرب اوكرانيا عاده يوجه ويطلب الشركات
الامريكيه النفطيه بزياده الانتاج هذه هذا
هو هذا التخبط بحد ذاته سواء داخل
الولايات المتحده او مع العلاقات الدوليه
اما بالنسبه الى قرارات اوبك فبالتاكيد
اولا كان في اكتوبر كان قرارا غير متوقعا
بخفض الانتاج لماذا لانه الولايات المتحده
تسعى الى
خفض اسعار النفط من اجل اداره عجله
اقتصادها ولكن في ذاك الوقت هناك مصالح
للدول المنتجه للنفط ولذلك عاد هذا الرد
الفعل قبل عشره ايام بقرار اوبك بينك خفض
الانتاج مع بدايه شهر منتصف شهر مايو
القادم ايار اكثر من مليون ونص برميل
يوميا هذا يجعل انه
الاداره الامريكيه لابد انه تجد حلا لهذه
الازمه في العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي ايضا
هناك تاثيرات اقتصاديه ايجابيه يعني
هناك لا ننسى هناك استثمارات اكثر من 110
مليار دولار في سندات الخزانه الامريكيه
من قبل المملكه العربيه السعوديه هناك
طلبات لاداره عجله الصناعات العسكريه
من قيمه العربيه السعوديه ولكن لابد من
ايجاد حل لهذه الازمه التي لابد ان تنتهي
قريبا دكتور عقيل اختم معك عن مستقبل
بايدن السياسي يعني في ظل عدم ايثائه ببعض
وعوده الانتخابيه في ظل هذا التخبط لدينا
اقوال تتضارب مع افعاله او قراراته في بعض
الاوقات كيف سيؤثر كل ذلك على مستقبلها
سياسي
يعني هناك اعتراضات من اطراف ديمقراطيه
باننا لسنا بايزاء قياده حاسمه يعني لا
اعتقد ولكنه ليست قياده حاسمه او ملهمه
ويعني احيانا يقول اشياء ينبغي ان لا
يقولها مع ذلك يعني التقليد في الولايات
المتحده انه اذا الرئيس قرر ان
يذهب لدوره انتخابيه جديده الحزب سيتبعه
حتى مع وجود هذه التحفظات بايدن ليست
شخصيه ملهمه خصوصا للشباب لشباب الحزب
الديمقراطي لكن ايضا هناك قناعه انه ان
ترشح
ترامب ويبدو ان الامور ذهبه نحو الترشح
سيستطيع ان يفوز عليه بسهوله في
الانتخابات الاخيره فاز عليه بحدود سبعه
ملايين صوت يعني هناك حسابات
تتعلق بترشيح السيد بايدن لا يعتبر
الديمقراطيون ان وجود خطر على الحزب لكن
هناك شكاوى منه جزء من الجيل القديم
ليس ملهما يتاخر ببعض الاشياء يعني هناك
مثل هذه التحفظات لكنها ليست حاسمه
واساسيه صحيح على كل سنبقى في انتظار
الا التطورات القادمه او شكركم الجزيل
الشكر من واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
في شؤون السياسيه الامريكيه ومن لندن
الدكتور مصطفى البزركان الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي والطاقه شكرا لكم معه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات